malgré tous les progrès technologiques
de notre époque les agriculteurs restent
à la merci du temps qu'il fait une façon
de réagir le plus rapidement possible
aux aléas de dame nature c'est d'avoir
sa propre station météo et c'est
exactement ce qu'on construit deux
jeunes en montérégie
nous sommes dans la ferme familiale
grégoire de l'antenne à saint cyprien de
napierville victoria 10 ans et matteo 9
ans font l'école à la maison avec leur
mère patricia alors qu'il se serait su
ils ont profité du confinement pour
fabriquer une station météo pour la
ferme dans le but de prendre les
meilleures décisions pour cultiver leurs
nouveaux potage le faire mais c'est une
ferme traditionnelle dans des grandes
cultures
j'essaie de développer comme des petits
laboratoires où est ce qu'on va
apprendre d'autres façons de faire
lecture de ton jeu l'inflation linge ou
est ce ici
trente sept longues années durant avant
de normalement fois mais c'est pas
n'importe quelle station météo
c'est une station météo de points 0,4 à
koné lorsque
l'emplacement de l'énergie au moteur qui
donne l'énergie on may et kobe qui
envoie le message à leurs inventaires
ici on voit le graphique les montres
séquencé pouvoir quand c'est moins fort
pour obtenir ces données
il faut s'approprier un nouveau langage
celui de l'ordinateur
il faut apprendre le codage vocal c'est
comme une sorte d'écriture que
l'ordinateur et il va comprendre cette
écriture pivot pouvoir faire des actions
avec les comme le mic au budget d'un
petit ordinateur donc quand je fais le
code lui il comprend ce langage savoir
coder comprendre ce langage là fait
partie d'une certaine littératie de base
là qu'ils peuvent certainement leur être
profitable d'ici 20 à 30 ans je suis
convaincu donc je suis plein de petits
films qui sont connectés à différents
pin
après ça s'est connecté un capteur qui
est ici tiens ça marche tous les jours
victoria et matteo mesure différents
paramètres météorologiques
d'après sincérité dassin jeux qui sont
pompés l'arrivée kiptoo de 22,2 de
rigueur c'est parfait maintenant si la
lumière sur cette lumière la d767 une
multitude celui d'être au 184 et
commerces à ses mines
ici c'est la salade victoria a aussi
planté des semis grâce à leur station
météo
les enfants savent exactement quand ils
doivent arroser
c'est facile pour moi parce que si tu
plantes juste en toi tu peux pas
vraiment le savoir précisément mais du
seul état
hier sur le temple beaucoup s'assurer
que nos plantes poussent bien une bonne
croissance ont de la bonne lumière
beaucoup d'eau dans un futur proche
l'objectif est que la production
agricole familiale profiter données de
la station météo
l'an prochain ils étudieront les
meilleures conditions pour la maturation
du maïs ils choisiront ainsi les
variétés les mieux adaptés
méchaal a bouclé ses valises
en maïs qu'il est charmant n'était ce
pas alors c'est moi
passionné de sciences et d'agriculture
victoria et matteo veulent devenir des
agriculteurs connecter la recette en ce
moment il ya des trucs ses détracteurs
tu contrôles le ton est pas de chez toi
c'est déjà sorti mais c'est pas toi de
mon poids moi je pense que j'aimerais
bien construire un robot qui plongerait
des graines par exemple des graines de
carottes parce que c'est long posés par
ce sont ces anodin comme ça tien an men
grain ça pousse pousse et c'est
merveilleux mais de comprendre la
science derrière ça je pense que ça peut
leur être utile pour être de meilleurs
agriculteurs avec le talent